Stanley has enjoyed cameos in a ton of
Marvel live-action movies including all
the films so far in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe a bunch of Fox's x-men and
Fantastic Four movies certainly
spider-man movies and of course
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 is no
exception
you PK me we lovers it's Jan here and as
I've already seen God into the galaxy
vol 2 I can tell you that his appearance
in the new movie is not only very funny
but it may also be a huge confirmation
of a popular fan theory about who Stan
Lee really is in the Marvel movie
multiverse by the way my guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 giveaway is running on
this video so for a chance to win make
sure you're subscribed and leave a
comment about the movie below I'll have
full details on the prizes at the end of
the video obviously spoilers lie ahead
for both Stan Lee's cameo and one of the
post-credits scenes in guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 however there are no
spoilers for the rest of the movie if
however you prefer a spoiler free video
you can tap in the top right for my
guardians to movie review so if you
haven't seen the movie yet here's what
happens
Stan the man appears on a moon dressed
in an old-style spacesuit chatting to
three watches after he complains about
being so rudely interrupted he says at
that time I was a Federal Express man
which is a reference to his brilliant
Toni stank line in Captain America Civil
War the three characters standing around
Stan VIII addressed like Watchers and
alien race in Marvel's comics as their
name suggests the watchers purpose is to
observe and record events throughout the
universe with a strict policy of
non-intervention because Stan Lee has
appeared in so many of Marvel's
annotations a popular fan theory
suggests that Stan Lee is actually a
watcher turning up in Marvel movies and
TV shows where he watches or observed
events in a cameo role in fact the
theory suggests that Stan Lee's
character is specifically the watcher
who were - a character created by Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby in 1963 the Fantastic
Four issue 13 why she was the watcher
who monitored events on earth and its
solar system however he has on occasion
broken the watchers code of
non-interference and actually intervened
in events watches are supposed to be
neutral and only Chronicle the events
they are observing and so why two of
interventions have sometimes landed him
in hot water if Stan Lee's character is
ooh-ah - it could explain why you've
sometimes got involved for example II
tried
pull up Thor's hammer in the first Thor
movie in spider-man 2 he saved a woman
from falling Gabri and in the incredible
health he was inadvertently key to how
events unfolded as he fell ill from
gamma sickness after drinking soda
contaminated with the Hulk's blood on
many occasions though Stan Lee pops up
as a bit of comedic relief generally not
affecting the plot of the movie so could
Stan Lee be the crucial element that
connects up all of the movies and TV
shows in Marvel's live-action multiverse
placing Stan Lee in a scene with a group
of Watchers in guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 seems to make this a real
possibility I mean Stan Lee isn't
dressed like a watcher but why is he
there in outer space talking to a group
of other Watchers where he seems to be
telling them all about his stories and
his recent escapades on earth in Captain
America Civil War maybe because he's
reporting back to the other Watchers
by the way it's also interesting the
watchers have now appeared in a Marvel
Studios film that it's previously been
thought that the rights the watchers who
might be with 20th Century Fox given
that the character who first appears in
a Fantastic Four comic and Fox owned the
film rights to the fantastic form if
this is the case that'll be interesting
to see if Marvel Studios did a trade or
exchange of rights for another character
like they did with egos our living
planet for guardians vol 2 but if you
thought that was it guardians the galaxy
vol 2 gives us a second scene with Stan
Lee right at the end of the credits in
the post-credits scene the watchers walk
off leaving Stan the man by himself
while he pleads for them not to leave
saying I thought you were going to give
me a ride and he also adds that you've
still got some more stories to tell that
last remark is obviously a meta joke
because Stan Lee of course had a hand in
creating many of Marvel's much-loved
characters but it could also add fuel to
the argument that he wants to tell them
about all his other cameos and
adventures in the Marvel movie
multiverse still it's funny how the
other watchers don't seem very
interested or impressed with Stan at all
now what do you think about Stan Lee's
cameo in post-credits scene in guardians
vol 2 do you think it proves he's really
been a watcher all along
or his Marvel just joking around with a
fan theory or maybe you have your own
theory about Stan Lee's role in the
Marvel movies don't forget to comment
and subscribe to enter my guardians to
giveaway surprise it includes two
awesome hardback books from DK guardians
of the galaxy the
that guides the cosmic outlaws which
takes an in-depth look at iconic
characters issues and storylines from
the comics and I've also got a selection
of three very cool Guardians Funko pop
vinyl figures so make sure you hit the
bell to turn on notifications so you
start to date with all my new videos and
if you enjoyed this video do hit that
thumbs up button and check out more of
my guardians of the galaxy vol 2 and
Marvel videos right here thanks for
watching and see you next time
you became a movie lovers